welcome to the UVM extension new farmer
project webinar Farm scale permaculture
techniques practices and philosophies
for permanent agriculture systems I'm
Jesse Schmidt and I work for the UVM
extension new farmer project I'll be
moderating this session our presenter
today is Keith Morris since 2000 he has
worked professionally as a designer
Builder and grower of ecologically
regenerative socially just and
culturally appropriate whole systems in
cities and sides around the world he
teaches at the University of Vermont the
yes tomorrow design build School
Sterling College Paul Smith's college
Burlington permaculture and has worked
for us Aid farmer to farmer in Nigeria
and Ghana welcome Keith ah thanks Jesse
it's a pleasure to be here um just uh as
far as sound goes is that sounding okay
to folks if you could maybe thumb up or
let me know that that sounds
good I think it sounds pretty good if
you might be able to pull your mic a
little bit away um it's just a little
muffled yeah okay I can pull it
away um great yeah it's a pleasure to be
here and I'm really excited to be a part
of the webinar series it's such a great
collection of resources already there in
terms of
webinars um yeah so um This was
um uh some stuff that we already did
here as far as the map so I think I'm
just going to skip through that and as
Jesse said um you know I work as a
designer um really my work as a designer
began um working for a variety of farms
um I started my own farm and I was 23 in
an interesting rent to own process it's
whe Crossing Farm um in Johnson Vermont
where we grow um fruit trees nut trees
bushes Vines medicinal herbs and we're
increasingly doing added value in terms
of um Farm oh um I'm hearing that I'm
not I can turn my mic
up how's that Ida does that sound a
little
better
um just let me know if there sound
issues again so um increasingly we're
doing kind of added value production in
terms of farm dinners and educational
events um my other business is um
Prospect Rock permaculture which is
really more of a design and education
aspect where I work with farmers and
other institutions and Community groups
to um help figure out how to make
Landscapes more productive and connected
um just a brief little history with that
if anyone's familiar with these two
areas geographically
um we wheel Crossing is an area that is
overlooked by Prospect Rock and um long
before there was such great aerial
photography that we have today I would
go up to prospect Rock a bluff on the
Long Trail and going to look down over
my farm in order to help me uh figure
things out and do some design work so um
we're going to be talking about peric
culture design as applied to
Farms um but this isn't intended as a
basic introduction to permaculture so um
it's a very very big field there's a lot
of things to explore um but for those of
you that aren't familiar the the word
comes not only from permanent
agriculture but also permanent culture
and kind of looking at how ecology can
better
inform the ways that we meet needs so
everything from food really as a
centerpiece you know um agriculture has
always been a centerpiece of
permaculture but also shelter also
energy also Waste Management um how
these things can be better connected and
modeled after what we see working in
natural systems so I have two
definitions here of per culture there
are hundreds um but meeting human needs
while increasing e ological health and
um the postmodern synthesis of all wise
human behavior a big part of
permaculture of course is studying
traditional techniques and recombining
them in in novel ways in in response to
some of the things that we're facing in
the 20th century so
um most mostly um prob culture is a
vision and a design system and it's a
network of people that's really where um
it's an exciting thing to be a part of
there's folks all over the world using
this design technique in order to
actualize this this vision of a
permanent
culture um it's basis is in ethics which
is something that's kind of unique in
Land Management Systems um and in slogan
form these are Earth care people care
and fair share
um which are kind of self-evident but
obviously we want to look take
responsibility for the resources that we
depend on natural systems that we depend
on but we're also caring for people um
and and it's really um about how as I've
said we're meeting human needs while
while improving ecological health and
recognizing that that isn't necessarily
a contradiction of terms although
there's certainly plenty of evidence to
to lead us to believe that that may be
the case um when we look at long-term
human needs obviously we need to have
good soil in which we grow our food we
need to have clean air we need to have
clean water um and then lastly and not
least importantly um be share meaning
limits to consumption limits to
population but most importantly
redistribution of our resources towards
better care of the earth and better care
of people um
so um that's the per culture ethics in a
nutshell if you aren't familiar with per
culture or even if you are um I just
point out here at the bottom the per
culture principles. comom website which
is really a great uh Resource as a as a
basic introduction to protoculture
ethics and
principles um the design principles are
varied and they're the things that we
learning from our study of traditional
culture and our study of
ecology and what's working in any
context and while we'll look at some
techniques that may be Place specific or
specific to a culture or E ecological
context really at its core these ethics
and principles will work wherever we
find ourselves in the world um so I
won't be getting too into depth with
these principles but we'll address them
a little bit um folks seeing my pointer
as I move it around the screen
um yeah so we'll be looking at how we
can integrate pieces of our systems to
be more mutually
beneficial um just to kind of give a
sense of the spectrum of protoculture
design I'll share with you the
protoculture flower and receive there's
these kind of seven points of action um
permaculture really encompasses how we
build the tools and Technologies we use
the education and our cultural aspects
um health and well-being finances and
economy land tenure and Community
governments and land in nature
stewardship so it's it's a very big uh
system and you know today we're really
going to be looking at just some of
these um maybe specifically
how we read
Landscapes and um you know how
agriculture fits in in terms of our land
and nature stewardship um but all of
these different pieces are kind of part
of our herbiculture toolkit um all right
so at any time if there's questions feel
free to type them into the box there um
I'm going to share a little bit more
about my own Farm just briefly we're
actually going to uh
do some time travel this is an aerial
photograph that was taken in 1942 of the
area where I farm and in 1942 they
started taking aerial
photographs um as a part of uh defense
strategies for World War II and they've
turned out to be some really great
resources for our understanding of Land
Management and um I'm not going to get
into too much detail but I just kind of
point out the curve of the river here as
it was in 1942 and also introduced these
photographs not only to share my own
Farm but to let you know that if you're
farming um You probably it's probably
going to be well worth your while to dig
into the archives of the map rooms of
the USDA or your local uh state land
grate University or wherever these files
may be archived because they will share
incredible insight to the Past of our
Landscapes so um as we travel through
time here we're going to see a couple of
things um one is that even in just a few
decades um we see tremendous changes
happening in our Landscapes and I'm sure
we're all well aware of that but to
really be able to quantify that in a
place specific way can be an incredibly
helpful tool in helping contextualize
our own decision making process and our
designs so in terms of this particular
site we see that obviously there's some
pretty severe erosion happening along my
Riverbank um also here as we move um
into 1995 we see the original farm and
Homestead and barn raised and put into
the ground where there's the beginnings
of a of a of a church um
constructed and we can see as I've
started to set up my farm some of the
changes happening in terms of ecological
secession both allowing some areas of
old pasture to to start to regrow and
you know here we are with one of the
more recent photograph Series where you
can kind of get a sense of um what's
happening on my farm which I'll talk a
little bit more
about
um I share that because it's really
critical that we make an effort to to
comprehend our place in our Landscapes
with long-term perspective and and do
that in order to have long-term
cooperation with the ecosystems that
we're coopera that we're you know
depending on and interacting with and
most importantly use that long-term
understanding as a as a point of
foresight so we can do some long-term
planning because that's um that's where
we're going to be heading here now is um
getting into some details of of how
we'll do um the actual work of design um
so the per culture design process it can
be done in a endless variety of ways but
in its simplest you know we want to be
very clear about what it is that we're
trying to achieve in terms of goals
articulation um let's
see okay and um we'll be working on maps
in terms of having an actual physical
record that we can refer to as we make
observations about our Landscapes um the
focus of today's talk is really going to
be How We Do site analysis and from that
analysis we're going to come up with
Design Concepts which are really very
kind of loose ideas and I know it's hard
for many of us especially if we're
Market Growers and I I actually I'll
I'll take a minute just to ask um who is
Farm and if folks wouldn't mind just
typing into the chat box there um if
you're farming if you're coming here
with a specific uh site in mind in terms
of where you want to apply this design
process um I'd be curious to see that um
okay great yeah um so we as Growers are
often really good at thinking about
specific props or varieties and we may
have some great skills in terms of
rotations and soil prep um and these are
all critical you know
foundational but um per culture is kind
of going to flip this around a little
bit and that we're not going to be
starting necessarily from an individual
crop or technique but really
contextualizing that in the whole of our
farm and this is why having a design
concept comes before detailed design in
our uh
in our design process here in that it's
really easy to determine exactly what
variety you want to grow and how far
apart it should be planted but what
we're trying to focus on is having more
importantly that these pieces are taking
place within the whole
um uh and and in better relationship to
all the other pieces of our farm so for
instance if we realize that we need uh
hedro or Windbreak on a farm maybe
before we even get into what species we
might be using in a hedro or Windbreak
is exactly how it's placed and how it
relates to some of our vegetable
production or grazing paddocks or
Vineyards or whatever other aspects we
may have so um this is great thanks
everyone for for chiming in with your um
this is great
so hi Kevin
okay so and then last of all of course
you know it's not just um you know the
designing but uh one of the most
important pieces is is actually doing
this right putting it in the ground and
then of course continuing to accept
feedback and recognizing that that these
systems are much more akin to sailing
ships and that we're constantly
adjusting the sales and our rigging
we're always accepting feedback and
responding to change we're responding to
Market we're responding to what's
working we're responding to what we're
enjoying um and it's it's a very Dynamic
process and unfortunately we're we're
never
done um okay so um goals articulation in
and of itself is something that honestly
we could do a full hour's webinar on
because it is so critical and and I
won't um spend a whole hour talking
about goals articulation but um I will
encourage enage any of you who are
planning to bring a design process to
your farm to do some very very thorough
goals
articulating um which is a little bit
different than goal setting right it's
it's about figuring out really what it
is that you're um that's really res
making your heart resonate right it's
not about kind of setting external
objectives and um on my website prospect
rock.org there is some educational
resources and in there is a document
that gives you some detailed exercises
to help you um articulate goals and
honestly even if you aren't yet farming
or even don't have a piece of land where
you're farming you may be even in the
best position to do some goals
articulation and as I work with clients
you know honestly a lot of times the
place I prefer to work with place at
least I have the highest Leverage is is
if folks have um some ideas but they
don't necessarily have a space yet um
meaning to say you know that you can do
a lot with any given piece of land but
if you know that you want to do
vegetable production or if you know you
want to do an apple orchard if you know
you want to be grazing animals having
those goals really clearly articulated
beforehand is really going to determine
the criteria that you use to choose
where you farm and um I can't I can't
understate that it's it's so important
that um that we you know
actually build these practices um if
possible you know I I recommend folks
start Market farming before they buy
land before they you know bite off a big
chunk of debt um really one of the
biggest pieces of course for Market
growing is is being strategic about
where you are relative to markets and
thinking about what you want to grow and
who's going to buy it and are you in a
position where Farm Stand makes a lot of
sense or whether there's a tourism
industry and there's a lot of
restaurants serving really good food so
um doing that goals articulation as soon
in the process as possible and
continuing to do it um is critical um
holistic management also offers a really
great toolkit for us in in doing some
goals articulation and um after the
session you may want to check in with
Jesse I'm not sure if they're still
doing a whole Farm planning course but
um for those of you who are in Vermont
there has been and I believe will be
again a uh a whole Farm planning course
which really helps Farmers through um
some of the business planning processes
and you know making sure that those
business plans really resonate with our
ourselves and our lives um here we go
thanks Jesse for the link um one one
piece of the goals articulation process
in holistic management that I want to
share here is just this idea of uh a
house and thinking of our goals really
as as a house the foundation being our
core values and our ethics those things
that we refuse to compromise on and
really being doing a lot of
introspection and thinking about
um you know why it is that you want to
farm and making sure that your daily
activities and all the work that you do
in terms of chores and and and your work
is kind of based on those ethics and
values rather than compromising them and
then one of the pieces that I think is
is really unique um is of course the
Legacy and thinking about in a
permaculture perspective
intergenerational
decision- making like
how we are leaving our farms and
landscapes for future generations of
people whether they're our own ancestors
or not um in the in the holistic
management
process one way of doing this is
actually writing your obituary which may
seem morbid to folks but um it's
actually can be very fun and to do this
I find just really offers such an
incredible Insight on um you know
writing down what we want to have said
after about us after we're gone and and
then having that as a as a written
document to refer to in our
decision-making process and
um be able to make decisions based on
that idea of Legacy like is is are this
decisions going to support that um that
Legacy that we're trying to create so
um excuse me in that vein of long-term
planning or or intergenerational
thinking um there's a couple other
things that I think you know are a part
of where permaculture design came about
in response to that are really critical
for us as our Growers and Farmers to be
considering in our farming plans um most
of you have probably heard about peak
oil and are somewhat familiar with it
I'm not going to go too in depth with it
but of course the reality at present is
that we're at a point in history where
we probably have the most resources
available to human beings at any time
before or after and for the whole Arc of
history of course you know we've we've
had more resources available than
previous generations have but we're
extremely novel in the new situation of
recognizing that we have more resources
available to us than previous
generations had excuse me then future
Generations will so um that's definitely
something to take into consideration
when we're thinking about our farm plans
um not only on the annual basis but on
the five or 10e basis and really
recognizing that this provides an
opportunity at present for us to in
invest energetic resources to invest
fossil fuels to build some of the
infrastructure that we may need that may
be more difficult to build in the future
so um and this is really kind of where
my business is positioned to a degree in
that we work with folks to establish
green houses and food processing
facilities and root sellers which quite
frankly are energetically intensive and
um can be expensive but when we look at
the return on those Investments over
years um they're not going to get any
cheaper to build and they'll start
paying back the minute you build them so
um we'll look at some other examples of
how we might invest fossil fuels into
our
systems but um here's just uh another
graph of the same kind of information
that also includes Consumer Debt load
which I think is really important piece
because um when we're thinking long term
we also want to recognize that a lot of
our Farms are present are very dependent
on global economic systems that are
frankly outside of our control
and the the challenge that we face as we
move into the 21st century is how we
make our farms and our communities um
locally viable and really food food
producers and land managers are at the
centerpiece of this potential for um for
resilient EOS economies for economies
that are not dependent on the whims of
the stock market or foreign exchange um
currency rates
so um that just sets some context as
well and then of course dealing with the
reality of climate change here we have a
graph of our 1990 USDA hardness map and
you know again anybody who's who wants
to just play with some of the
interactive technology feel free to just
you know throw your little dot on the
map and we'll look at how this changes
from 1990 to 2006 um sorry I just wiped
away everyone's dots but um I'll go back
and do it again we're seeing a pretty
clear trend of moving hardiness zones
and in some areas of the country that
can mean actually cool cooler um here in
Vermont there's very very clear evidence
that we're seeing um warmer weather and
especially warmer Winters um as far as
the act the objective records go um that
has major implications for our food
systems you know when we look to the
forecasts of climate we see you know
this is New Hampshire but um with
aggressive reduced emissions scenarios
where you know we Implement carbon
sequestration and and reduce emissions
we're still looking at New Hampshire
behaving as the virginas by the end of
the century although more likely we're
looking at New Hampshire behaving as the
Carolinas um so these are all factors
that that we want to take into play as
we think about what techniques we use
what crops we use what strategies we
employ and you know I'm not trying to be
the uh the harbinger of do here but the
more closely we pay attention to climate
scientists really the scarier this stuff
gets right um we're seeing here this
kind of Arc of temperature and
um just notice how close we are to
temperatures that human beings have not
lived on the planet in and then of
course the forecast for our present
emissions um clim climactic response to
our present emissions so I'm not trying
to scare any one here um but I am trying
to maybe do some goals articulation for
all of us collectively in terms of the
importance of making our Farms carbon
negative of making our Farms climate
resilient
because
unfortunately with all of the forecasts
and models out there honestly um no
predictions are going to be that
accurate everything's unfolding more
rapidly than was imagined and the only
things that we can really be certain of
are increased incidents of severe
weather we're going to see late Frost
we're going to see early Frost we're
going to see drought we're going to see
you know torrential downpour here in
Vermont most of you arew that we've seen
um secessions of record-breaking floods
just in the past few years and that's of
course a major factor for me for those
of you who are just looking at the um
aerial photograph farm you may have
noticed that we're right in the river
valley um also now is that chance to
invest fossil fuels to set up systems
that don't need them as constant daily
inputs in the future and um whether
that's investing in Alternative Energy
Systems or um irrigation systems that um
and and and fertility cycling systems so
that we we are not stuck with um our
systems being completely dependent on
things that are outside of our control
if if your agricultural model involves
for instance buying in a lot of grain um
you know that's fine to to to make sure
that you're you're meeting your your
bills but you may want to be making a
five or 10 year plan to start producing
more of your own feed or build
relationships with other local producers
that may help you in that because um
obviously not only the trucking but um
having brain come from very far away
just puts it in an increasingly fragile
situation um okay and and then you know
not least important is really thinking
about how our economies are vibrant in
local systems and really starting to
weave these connections among local
producers um
because honestly Global e global economy
um are outside of our control the
forecasts don't look good but that said
I'm I'm not trying to look into a
crystal ball here um but what I am
saying is that we see healthy economies
happening all over and we can make an
intention to be a part of them more
directly and to create these
relationships among local producers and
our local communities that really bring
real economic health economic health
that's based on appropriate student ship
of of of resources and regeneration of
resources as as good Farms are capable
of doing um okay and as you know we're
seeing things like the food safety
modernization act and all these other um
you know uh Staples Commodities debt
speculation all these things that are
somewhat outside of our control are um
we're we able to insulate ourselves to
them as we build real relationships with
real people on a face-to-face basis um
you know it's very concerning I'm sure
many of you who are Growers are paying a
lot of close attent especially smaller
Growers are paying a lot of attention to
the food safety modernization act and
all of these certification processes
even organic become less relevant when
we know our customers our customers know
who we are um and we're directly engaged
um so when when when people know who
they can trust they they all become
necessary of course and that's the
reason we're seeing the demand for these
types of laws is because when food
production is totally out of sight with
zero relationship um there's a lot of
risk um in terms of health so let's take
an opportunity now to build these
relationships preemptively so that we're
well positioned despite the
frankly potentially you know corporate
controlled regulation that that's
unveiled um okay so getting back to our
kind of landscape design
process
um we'll I'll just go back to our um
design process as a whole for a brief
second if I can find the right slide
yeah sorry I I drew all over it but um
so we're doing some articulation um and
let's presume we've done some base
mapping for for most of you you know
unfurling a big piece of paper and
drawing a map of your farm by hand is
going to suffice honestly to do this at
detail with scale for the Big Ideas is
less important certainly as you get into
some of the more detailed aspects like
how many of a certain plant or how wide
certain rows are you're going to need to
work at scale but for the big picture
ideas rough and out of scale is is
better than doing it too scaled because
I find you know if we try to make these
Maps too carefully we don't have as much
fun just kind of throwing our ideas out
on paper but really the center piece of
the process is um better understanding
our Landscapes and that site analysis
and
assessment and
um we can do that through What's called
the scale of permanence
and the scale permanence is something
that actually is predates
permaculture but um it's a really great
tool that we have to understand our
leverage essentially so starting from
climate which
is sure globally and Society wide we're
impacting climate but on our own
individual Farms there's not much that
our decisions affect how much rain we
get in a year how cold it gets during
the winter um you know where we are
relative to the equator or poles and
we're primarily responding to that
that's not something we're designing for
whereas as we get down to the other end
of the spectrum things like how our farm
feels to people when they walk on or
what it looks like is entirely under our
control and so this spectrum is
basically from the most permanent
aspects of our landscape um down to the
least permanent or I should say the ones
that are most easily influenced by
Design so that doesn't mean so we're
designing in response to these aspects
and then increasingly we're able to
design these um along our own goals so
starting with
climate
um obviously things like average
precipitation um and rainfall are great
but we want to look not just to averages
but also to extremes and especially
recently you know averages
are great Baseline information to pay
attention to but we also want to know
what is the most rain that we've ever
had what is the longest drought that
we've ever had um what is the hottest
that it's ever gotten what is the
coldest that it's ever gotten and make
our Farms as resilient as possible not
just to averages but also to extremes um
and then of course as as I think I've
already um made clear we really need to
pay attention to how climate's changing
and anticipate that and as a part of our
climate analysis so here we see a more
detailed um hardiness zone map is an
updated one for Vermont and we also see
the Vermont State climate Trends um
looking over the past 50 years um which
is showing um pretty clear warming trend
based on the numbers as well as um much
more extreme warming during winter
months um which might have some
advantages for us as Growers frankly but
also has some
disadvantages and as I mentioned earlier
the reality of these forecasts is that
the the the climate change is kind of a
um it's it's almost a misleading phrase
because it it seems to indicate gradual
unify uniform benign predictable whereas
I think this phenomenon is better
understood as as climate chaos or
climate collapse and I I don't mean to
say that things are hopeless but I mean
to say we really want to buffer
ourselves from floods we want to buffer
ourselves from winds we want to have as
much diversity as possible in our crops
and and techniques so that something's
always winning um regardless of what's
Happening you know I'm here um in
Northern Vermont in what's classically
considered a Zone 3 and we had bumper
crops crops of peaches um and as far as
I know they were the first peaches ever
grown in theor valley of Vermont and we
just happen to have the right conditions
during pollination that um we had great
fruit set and I'm not banking on having
a peach CR every year but it's pretty
exciting
and um I think you know we all have a
little room to do some
experimentation in regards to um
variables okay
um all right so landform then is kind of
our next most permanent after climate
and let's see if I can get my little
drawing thing here yes perfect so
great
um so obviously you know things like a
basic sorry
folks things like a basic toppo map of
course can be really really helpful
information here but really um it might
be that you just sit down and kind of
draw everything that has anything to do
with the land form of your farm steep
Ledges where you see Boulders or Bedrock
expressed um what's flat what's Steep
and kind of we're making these maps on I
make them on tracing paper so that I can
um I can overlay them one after another
um this particular topo map is from
Libra
maps.org
um it's the USGS topography but it's um
huge Contour intervals and honestly
doesn't tell us very much about our
Farms if you've ever had a survey done
or if there's any surveys on record with
um uh having done a septic system or
anything like that these are going to be
way more detailed and in some cases it's
totally worth paying a surveyor or
working with your you know your USDA and
or CS you might be able to support these
things depending on what practices
you're trying to do so we recently
actually I'm sorry I wasn't able to
upload it into the slideshow but we
recently had an actual you know micro
topography made of our farm um and just
kind of looking at these patterns of
erosion and deposition and how that
influences the big big overlays of the
way our Farms work um water of course is
an is another one um and in the case of
my particular Farm what we're looking at
overlaid here is essentially the flood
plane and you can kind of see in the
layout of crops um as as if you can see
in the land of crops we're kind of on
these islands in the flood plane which
is which is fortunately positioned that
way because we've had opportunity to
observe multiple hundred-year floods and
in the past few years we've seen two or
three 500e floods um
and one of the
main efforts of our farm is to be
reforesting um buffers so that our more
sensitive production some of the more
valuable crops are um protected so when
we put water and land form together we
end up with a wide variety of techniques
but um what we're looking at here is an
image of what's called keyline design
specifically we're looking at Mark
Shepard's Farm in Wisconsin um who's
this was farm this was a cornfield this
was Bare black dirt when he started
and um the entire layout is arranged
over very nuanced expressions of
topography and keyline design is is
again another topic that's kind of a a
whole webinar in and of itself um but
long story short what we're looking at
is managing water as it moves off our
landscape so instead of our kind of
conventional management which is
shunting shunting water to a drainage
ditch where it close off the farm as
quickly as possible we're spreading it
out along so basically you know the flow
of the hills in this direction and as
rainwater rolls over the farm instead of
gaining speed and momentum and carrying
soil off it is spread across the farm
and these ditches are actually not
they're not really ditches but they're
um these um they are like kind of plow
lines that are not actually on Contour
they are slight off Contour so that
water is being better distributed
towards the dry ridges and and and
making it more even um also of course
tremendously preventing erosion also of
course instead of having all that water
fly off of our Farms when we get tons of
rain and then it's dry it's storing that
water in our systems and basically
working like a battery so that we're
between heavy rain and periods of dry
were way balanced in the middle so
here's here's Mark Shepard here um and
in these rows of trees he's growing Oaks
uh sweet Acorn Oaks he's growing
chestnuts he's growing hazelnuts he's
grazing animals he's um on rotation
doing annual vegetables um it's it's a
really great example of kind of farm
scale permaculture design so here's just
a little bit more of what key line can
look like this is in Australia where um
you know water scarcity is a major issue
especially on pasture land and this is
key line where the key line management
is specifically diverting water into
these ponds which are then able to be
released as passive irrigation so no
pumps just entirely Gravity by holding
water as high as it's possible in the
landscape um um for for many of us um
this may not necessarily mean ponds but
it could mean something like a water
tank um in fact we just recently were
citing a livestock shelter at a farm for
some friends and decided to put the
livestock shelter on the highest
possible part of the landscape we put it
basically on the top of the hill and we
did that because we put a huge roof on
the livestock shelter which a made for
nice Shady space for the animals in the
summer it's open walled with the open
walls facing south so that it creates
this warm microclimate for the animals
during the winter months and that whole
roof area is used to fill a giant it's a
2,000-gallon water tank um which fills
almost instantly I think most of us
aren't aware of how a drain really comes
in an event you're you're going to get
um6 gallon
approximately 6
gallons per inch of rain per square foot
of roof area so you do the math on that
100 square feet which is an incredibly
small building you're going to get about
60 gallons of water just of 100 square
feet so you put a thousand or a few
th000 gallon water tank there and in the
case of this instance we had all the
water needs for the livestock there from
the rainwater catchment without having
to run plumbing up there and then we had
because it was at the top of the hill
the ability to run a hose out of it to
any other parts of the Garden or pasture
completely passively without any pumps
so um there's another example of key
Line Design and then another aspect of
key line is the key line plow and this
is how these ditches can be made to
manage the water as I said and they're
also used of course to deepen top soil
and bring the organic and biologic
components of soil a little bit deeper
which is being used which with
Incredible success by a organization
known as carbon farmers and carbon
farmers are essentially quantifying to
what degree they're sequestering
atmospheric carbon in their soil simply
by deepening their top soil and of
course it makes plants more productive
um it makes pastures healthier um and is
is it holds incredible promise for um
for sequestration of atmospheric
carbon okay so vegetation in Wildlife is
another we're we're not necessarily
going through every layer of the scale
of permanence but um I encourage you to
um you know if you come back and view
this slideshow you know you can you can
go to slides like this and also I'll
Direct toward some resources where these
things can be found online but
essentially every single one of these
needs to be thought about very very
carefully and then put together and it's
a lot of fun to do um it it does take
time but it's time that's infinitely
worthwhile and as we overlay these
different things as different Maps we
find that no matter how intimately
familiar we are with our farms and
Landscapes you'll come to new
discoveries you're going to learn um and
one of the reasons I like to do it with
tracing paper is of course as I overlay
different layers on top of each other
for instance microclimate on top of
vegetation and Wildlife I may find why
there's different ecological communities
on different parts of the farm um more
obviously I me come to understand why
we're seeing some of these
differences um especially water and
access you know as we overlay those we
may learn the catchment area that's
really coming through a CT or something
like that and better understand why
we're seeing roads blow out um and uh
have some different opportunities for
management okay so vegetational Wildlife
is is one of the bigger ones and one of
the more complex ones it's one you know
you can spend a lot of time just you
know identifying the vegetation on your
farm um you you can um look things up in
field guides which is really great one
um process that I really like is using
field Guides of natural communities
which are a little bit different than
the field guides that you might use for
say identifying an individual tree or
shrub or wildf flower um field guides to
Natural communities are field guides to
the groups of plants and animals and how
they interact which is very very help
ful for us when we're doing um
broadscale Farm design to understand
exactly what ecological community that a
farm once was or could be in the case of
my farm here um as we look at Islands
like this and we look at the the the
semblance of vegetation that was left on
this hay field um this uh would key out
as What's called the sugar maple ostrich
Fern flood plane Forest um so
that's um an incredibly valuable tool
for us to use as a point of inspiration
um on the one hand it shows me okay that
you know we already have very valuable
vegetation in the over story and the
under story both sugar Maples and
fiddleheads or ostrich F but um more
importantly it allows me to do what we
call ecological analoges so as we
determine which plants we are looking in
as
crops um we can look for instance to the
butternut which is juggling CA one of
the Native nut trees to this community
however the butternut is subject to a
blight and they're diseased so we're
working at hybridizing the butternut
with the Japanese Walnut the heartnut to
create something that's a little bit
more valuable to us a little bit more
resilient that said we're still planting
butternuts we have a lot of hope for
them and as we go on with this
hybridization we're finding some of the
ones most suitable to our specific place
um another kind of halfstep analog of
course is the black walnut and as we're
looking at climate
change um we're also of course
anticipating uh warmer weather and
experimenting even with the Carpathian
Walnut which um I wouldn't necessarily
recommend spending a lot of money
investing in if you're if you're in
Northern Vermont but by all means
potentially experimenting with it's a
it's a the carping Walnut being uh
typically not Hardy but the one of the
more valuable in terms of Walnut
production it's you know the walnuts
that you buy in the supermarket are
almost entirely jugin regia the
Carpathian
Walnut um and the shag bark Hickory Kio
ovada and even karia ilanis which is our
peacon and quote unquote you can't grow
peons in Vermont but um my peon trees
haven't read the books so they are doing
fine and we'll see you know whether
we're going to be getting uh nuts
ripening in our short season um we're
not banking on them we're not planting
them entirely but um I think I really
just want to drive around in a nut
Shaker which is one of the reasons why
uh I'm planting so many nut trees but
also of course because of where my farm
is um in terms of floods so let's let's
actually go to the kind of overall
concept of the farm a little bit um
which
is you know we're you we're still doing
some annual production we're still doing
some tillage but all of that tillage is
contextualized in the establishment of
what we're calling productive buffers
now any buffers is good and there's some
great um programs out there to subsidize
and support folks reforesting along the
River's Edge but they're pretty strictly
um purely native plants that are not
productive and um that's good but when
you look at the the the the finances a
lot of farmers of course are somewhat
reluctant to enter these relationships
because their crops may be much more
valuable than their buffers but when
we're looking at high value Lumber when
we're looking at nuts fruits medicinal
herbs Vines berries um it it may take a
few more years but we're looking at
things that are actually yielding more
value in the long run than any crop
they'd be growing in The River's Edge
but which with with permanent Roots so
um I'm very excited about the potential
for reforesting agriculture but by no
means do I mean to say that you know all
of our Farms totally be reforested um
it's always going to take shape
completely differently based on every
different farm and every different
farmer goals um for our farm it is high
value fruits nuts medicins and um and
Vines and berries especially
concentrated in the areas that are prone
to erosion um we're working with the
Anglers Association who recognize the um
the ability to shade the stream and
prevent nutrients from washing into the
river and most importantly for us as
floods come through our farm having
these buffers established prevents
immediate physical damage from flopam or
Woody debris or icebergs um which we see
pretty regularly and also makes for
incredible habitat so this was an
earlier draft of our design and um we
see here kind of a more recent one and
this one was a map done specifically for
our irrigation plan but um if you look
in the upper portion um I'm not sure if
that's too small to be read but um you
can see kind of our layout and how what
I'm getting at when I'm stressing this
idea of a design concept which is to say
that of course it's important to plan
your rotations and have things spaced at
the right distance
but more importantly is thinking about
the big picture of the parts of our farm
and how they fit together as an organism
as a whole um so and how are animals
able to integrate with some of our other
production systems for instance here we
see one of our production rows of
hazelnuts um in the fall as the
hazelnuts are ripening we fence our
chickens in which completely weed the
plants fertilize the plants and prevent
squirrel pation as well as um being kind
of isolated in the areas of high
activity um which really limits how much
squirrels are willing to risk getting
across the farm um which kind of leads
me to introduce another one of our um
design principles which is zones of use
um which is essentially a tool looking
at like our daily patterns of activity
on a farm um starting out you know in
your bedroom when you wake up and
thinking about how our chores unfold
based on our normal daily activity and
if you find yourself you know needing to
cross the entire Farm to get to the
dairy barn or the greenhouse or some of
these High um maintenance tasks you're
spending a lot of time and energy that's
not that productive and maybe you're not
able to move your barn or Greenhouse but
you can make the path from your door to
there um where your main garden rows are
so that as you're walking through them
you're able to at least keep an eye on
things if not even pull some weed or do
some harvesting and really as much as
possible lay our Farms out along the um
the putting things which need the most
attention in the places where they're
going to get it um one of the reasons
undoubted that we had such success with
our peaches is I put my peach in a place
where I walk by it every single day and
I have a few trees
and the ones that I don't see they don't
get watered when it's dry they don't get
thinned whereas the one that I was
walking by day in and day out if a bug
was biting a peach I noticed it I picked
that one off um if there was a bow
starting to eat the bark um which did
happen to one of the ones kind of out of
the way
um I was able to respond to that
immediately so put things that need care
and attention in the places where
they're naturally going to get it as
much as possible um I I I think um we
can kind of start to summarize and I
might like to um uh provide an
opportunity for any other comments or
questions before we end but most
importantly I just want to encourage you
to make maps have a lot of fun kind of
draw out your dreams and really think
things through you know does design can
be intimidating but it's also an
incredible amount of fun and you know
it's it's iterative we're always
learning and we're always making
mistakes but when we can make those
mistakes on paper um it saves us a lot
of time energy and resources um and get
out in the landscape and you know use
some stakes and flagging and if you're
thinking about you know where you might
site your barn or Greenhouse or or one
of your next rows maybe flag it or stake
it first and walk by it for a few weeks
and really feel it out I'm planning on
building a barn at my farm right now and
I staked the four corners and had it
there to the point that I saw the barn
and people would be you know walking
across this open area of grass and I was
like oh you're standing in my barn and
what happened one day I pulled in with a
trailer behind my truck and I couldn't
make the turn without clipping the
corner of the barn however fortunately
the corner of the barn was simply a
wooden stake that hadn't been
constructed yet and I was able to kind
of accept that feedback and learn that
the this position of the bar needed to
move if I wanted to continue to access
that one route with truck and trailer um
so as we we close on these images here I
just want to share the aogi farm which
is in Putney Vermont um really
absolutely inspiring Pioneers in growing
rice um
in Vermont and the uh Mr rogi's you know
a Japanese born American who reads
Japanese and has been reading all the
research that has happened in the past
few years to
bring uh rice to the northern islands of
Japan and these are areas of their farm
that would have otherwise been
considered unproductive kind of spongy
Fields this is you know what they look
like in the early season turned into
some of the most beautiful productive
and profitable areas of their farm so
the more we can kind of think through
how problems might be made into
Solutions and how all these pieces
integrate and reciprocate to to feed off
of each other um the the more resilient
our Farms
become so anyway um we're nearly closing
if there are any last comments or
questions feel free to um throw them in
the box there I'm sorry we only had an
hour obviously it's kind of a teaser
there's a lot of
information um to try to fit but I hope
you found it worthwhile and um stay
tuned to the UVM extension webinars next
week is going to be uh uh one on Shake
mushrooms which I'm excited about and um
here Jesse shares our our link for
feedback
so um
yeah great everyone um thank you so much
for join
hey everyone um thanks for joining us
and thank you so much Keith for being
with us um and and uh we really
appreciate all the information you
shared um Tina Barney had a question hi
Tina uh she said do current use
reviewers recognize permaculture
principles as valid and supported and
for those of you outside of Vermont
current use is a
regulation that uh values property at an
agriculture um for agriculture use and
has tax implications keth do you have
any experience with that um yeah thanks
so current use definitely values having
uh design on paper um um so they you
know they've definitely it it depends
which is really kind of the answer to
all regulatory questions right but um if
you have a working plan
um you definitely need to be producing
something whether it's you know whether
it's pasture hay apples berries um even
Timber but um the better recorded you
have that and and the better documented
you have any planning or planting or
implementation um the easier it's going
to be to to get current
use great um and uh Mike Gibson asks um
about young nut trees and looking for a
good place to purchase them um and also
do you grow yours from cuting or do you
purchase your trees yeah great so we
have a nursery mic that's become one of
the biggest growing parts of our farm is
selling young trees um particularly the
Hazels where um we are now at the point
of nut production with our hazelnuts
that we're you know we're planting our
seed out um from our own trees that
we've collected in terms of some of the
walnuts and chestnuts um and and pine
nuts and other nuts like that we both
collect seed we do Buy in some nuts um
but um my website is Prospect
rock.org which um you might want to
check out we're going to be doing some
of our Nursery sales and depending on
where you are you know feel free to send
me an email because if if you're not in
Vermont I may know of some other um
reputable
nurseries um
it's um it's a really exciting crop for
for for me and for us um it does take a
little bit time to get established but
but we've started you know really
carefully running the numbers and the
return on investment after a few years
is is um is better than than most
things great Keith thanks and I know
that some work has been done on uh
permaculture and looking doing Financial
um projection for permaculture based
Farms um can you let people know about
that that resource um uh because I I
know that for Farmers a lot of them want
to be able to uh look at Financial
projections and better understand how
these things are going to contribute to
their bottom line yeah it's pretty nent
but um there is you know some growing
documentation and it's at this point
somewhat crop-based there's some records
that I'm aware there's there's a a real
body of Records growing with um with
Saskatoon in Canada and you know so all
your Amal launcher your juneberries and
your you know shadbush or whatever you
want to call them um
Elderberry
um there is I'm sorry that I don't have
it off the top of my head but there is a
database um which again maybe if you
want to just try to send me an email I
could see if I could um share the link
for what is
uh what they basically got some like
accounting spreadsheets for a couple
different
Enterprises great well thank you very
much I see that some people might be
having a trouble with our Survey Monkey
link uh requiring a sign in um I'll have
to double check on that it shouldn't um
so try the link again when you get a
chance um but I'm going to wrap up now
and say thanks to everybody for joining
us Keith thank you so much for taking
the time to put this together and uh we
look forward to seeing everyone on
future webinars uh have a great
afternoon thanks Jesse and thanks
everyone